a circle is centered at the point c
which has the coordinates negative one
comma negative three and has a radius of
six
where does the point p which has the
coordinates negative six comma negative
six lie and we have three options inside
the circle on the circle or outside the
circle
and the key realization here is just
what a circle is all about if we have
the point c which is the center of a
circle
a circle of radius 6 so let me draw that
radius so let's say that is its radius
it is 6
units the circle will look something
like this
remember the circle is a set of all
points that are exactly 6 units away
from that center
so that's that's the definition of a
circle it's a set of all points that are
exactly six units away from the center
so
if for example p
is less than six units away it's going
to be inside the circle if it's exactly
6 units away it's going to be on the
circle and if it's more than 6 units
away it's going to be outside of the
circle so the key is is let's find the
distance between these two points if the
distance is less than 6 inside
distance equals 6 we're on the circle
distance more than 6 we are outside of
the circle so let's do that so if we
wanted to find and there's different
notations for the distance
well i'll just write d or i could write
the distance between c and p
is going to be equal to
and the distance formula comes straight
out of the pythagorean theorem but it's
going to be the square root
of our change in x squared plus our
change in y squared so what is our
change in x so our change in x if we
view c is our starting point and p is
our endpoint but we could do it either
way
our change in x
our change in x is negative 6
minus negative 1.
so negative 6 minus negative 1
and we're going to square it so what we
have inside here that is change in x so
we're taking our change in x squared
and then plus our change in y squared so
we are going
we're going from negative 3 to negative
6. so our change in y is negative 6
minus negative 3
negative 6 minus negative 3 and we're
going to square everything
so that is our change in y inside the
parentheses and we're going to square it
so this is equal to
this is equal to negative 6
negative 6 plus
positive 1 is one way to think about it
so this is negative 5
squared and then this is negative 6
plus 3 so plus negative 3 squared and
once again you can see our change in x
is negative 5. we go 5 lower in x and
we're going 5 3 lower and y so our
change in y is negative 3. so this is
equal to the square root of
25 square root of 25 plus 9.
square root of 25 plus 9 which is equal
to the square root of 34.
now the key is is the square root of 34
less than 6 greater than 6 or equal to 6
well we know that 6 is equal to the
square root of 36
so the square root of 34 is less than
the square root of 36 so i could write
the square root of 34 is less than the
square root of 36 and so the square root
of 34 is less than 6 these are square
root of 36 is 6.
and so since the distance between c and
p
is less than 6 we are going to be on the
inside of the circle if i somehow got
square root of 36 here then we'd be on
the circle and if i somehow got square
root of 37 here or something larger we
would have been outside the circle